hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch from
watchmojo.com one of the greatest
channels ever 20 million subs damn pops
top 10 bad guy good guy movie team-ups
this is good this is good knowledge to
obtain one of our topper war tears over
at our patreon page is whatever video
your question was due and put up on
youtubes and today comes from the man
named Mikhail Linden and we'll give you
a proper shot at the end of this video
but I just did want to say if you guys
haven't ever been to the new rock stars
YouTube channel go check them out
produce a great channel they're not
asking us to do that they don't even
know who we are
I just love watching their vids and I
want to recommend these guys who are
[Music]
[Music]
experienced or can't go back and watch
those movies
yeah so distracted by they leave a scar
Oh will so the door can save Jane from
an ancient power that threatens the
realms in return it's because of this
display of brotherly love that this
team-up is interesting it shows that
they do care for each other we need all
the bitterness
I'm gonna have like a lot of scenes oh
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
I'm the pianist
last last 20 minutes
yeah they're all got it now I knew it
was you know maybe I didn't well
investigates him for years
once Frank is in prison these two
characters team up to put Frank's
expertise in forging checks to use oh
yeah Barry oh great
I donate my wings it shows that true
friends can be found in the most
unexpected places never said Godzilla
Mothra and Rodan he doing Godzilla king
of the monsters just watch this one
before seems like it's mainly
installment Tokyo is under attack by
Vidura a three-headed two-tailed gravity
beam breathing dragon whoa the very same
day that Godzilla and Rodan appear
yeah but the new gut the two are
perfectly happy to exchange blows with
one another I forgot good in the all the
time Western Scottish blondie start off
on the wrong foot
this only gets worse when blondie turns
his back on their first partnership
which involves making money over and
over again off of to County a great deal
of antagonism is born out of this
incident but it's put aside in favor of
locating two hundred thousand dollars in
gold of which only blondie knows the
exact location so they form a shaky new
alliance to prevent angel eyes from
finding the treasure first working with
this team so fascinating they never
really trust each other mostly for each
other
[Music]
James Bond whoa we can't disengage the
dummy system as jammers
number two Rocky Balboa that's good you
know these two boxers have been at odds
with each other from the beginning but
when Rocky's trainer
maybe passes away due to a heart attack
yeah we know see actors like this buck
it's not weird back then that was rare
friendship is born through these trials
and tribulations Hey in the end it leads
to Rocky second heavyweight championship
title
[Music]
note battle no faster
rocky and Apollo's new bond well their
rivalry was intense friendship Peter and
number three Xavier and Magneto which
one needs a future past those are
Brotherhood x-men work together at x2
x-men United to save mutantkind
it's actually x-men Days of Future past
the takes third place on our list since
it sees Xavier and Magneto teaming up in
both the present and the past all the
wounds are patched as young Xavier and
Magneto joined forces to prevent killing
machines from nearly destroying all
mutants in the future but there even
stops the Alliance team despite a few
bumps along the way part with respect
for one another
can't they just admit that they love
each other already
they're still friends it is riveting to
see these two work together knowing that
they are only using each other this
indicates that you plan to allow Kong
the very men we were sent here to
destroy not a lot away from using it
before we unveil our number one pick
here are some honorable mentions yeah
guys does anyone uniform one of us has
to go on the other one shoulders
oh man what is this Shakespeare
adaptation blade - I love this movie not
most important
you know we in order to gain Lecter's
professional advice she needs to deal
with him to exchange personal
information about herself but she has to
chase to put back in jail after his
impressive escape but oh easily
oh what a pun what a pun he was really
Roger Moore or James Bond the real man
Roger Moore yeah no I did not but uh
that's exciting to know um I appreciate
his performances as a womanizer that
much fun morbo Hobson siya man yeah as
long as John Campea show and they asked
me of my a lot had it coming camp haha
or justice for Han camp I'm like oh your
[ __ ] love ha I barely remember the guy
was he a villain at first and then he
joined the Fast and the Furious
franchise where I watch Han or Jason
Statham I'm gonna watch Jason Statham in
the rock every one of these sets at the
beginning
technically yeah not maybe technically
in the first movie Vin Diesel's a bad
guy so he appalled Walker one of the
greatest team-up our time thinking of
like other team ups but I know there are
some good ones listen an alien versus
Predator the first time a predator
teamed up with a human yeah sort of
because the at least they look like
scientists lady yeah they have a moment
where they make eye contact and then she
like lets her go and yeah like there's
sympathy there they totally work
together in that one mmm-hmm
I'd also say but not better than
predators yeah I know that's definitely
better in predators Loki and Thor you
know looking back over this imagery I'm
like yeah Thor the dark world doesn't
get credit for its cinematography and
its costume design and makeup there's a
lot of that cool technical aspects means
let's talk story-wise gonna talk about
that but I mean come on just breezing
over these images just like dance looks
so cool it did make me want to re-watch
it that's kind of crazy remember is Jane
getting the Asgard and being unfazed
yeah I'm making a lot of jokes
I thought it was funny that predators
made the list because it's so brief I
know yeah and especially as they reveal
to us the way that whole thing plays out
it's like it's a very short moment but I
just admire that movie for how badly
Adrien Brody wanted to be in it yeah
yeah man he really went the extra really
what if he really was full Christian
Bale in that movie oh yeah
gruff voice and everything catch me if
you can I put this higher on the list
yeah because that movie had a surprise
turn of events if he did a wikipedia the
true story which at the time we competed
it now exists because I was under the
impression I was gonna get caught this
based on true story I didn't know this
turn of events would actually take place
celebrate the criminal in this movie
well they actually have some kind of
bond by the end of it and he also comes
to work for them yes cat-and-mouse game
but that it ends up turning into a
friendship it weirdly ends on a happy
note yeah and it's you feel that
happiness and that's the movie that
brought a lot of the population like
fully on board Leonardo DiCaprio as an
adult go gangs in New York and catch me
if you can both came out in the same
month yeah as his comeback time I love
that Moonraker is on here hey finally
some respect for Moonraker Rocky Balboa
and Apollo Creed is a great call because
without them becoming friends we
wouldn't have the Creed franchise now
yeah and it has greatly affected the
rocky franchise because you know they're
kind of enemies in the first one the
second one they're like you know this is
a versus movie yeah the third one they
become buds and it greatly affected the
remainder of the franchise yeah and it's
a turn that feels at least as I recall
it it feels like a kind of natural thing
to do I mean their peers like of all
these movies they're the least
vehemently opposed to each other it's
more about the circumstances yeah I love
them together man yeah I love them
together especially like patting each
other on the beach dude that was the
best homoerotic sequence ever when
they're running on the beach where's
that list get that top guns volleyball
see that's homoerotic see cuz that is so
hard like it's the one directed that
movie and that's why it's even funnier
to me because it's typically took shots
of close-up on their thighs when they're
running we worked out hard and we're
gonna demonstrate that every muscle we
did not skip leg day it's important
Xavier Magneto that's a good call it's
funny that I didn't even realize it in
x2n Days of Future past they work
together and in both movies magneto
turns on them at the end of course he
does he has to go back to being bad
again not in Apocalypse August's been
reversed he was bad in a heath band on a
good note yeah cuz there's a bigger
badder yeah if there's a Trekkie fans
have made its at this point I think I
was able to appreciate Benedict
Cumberbatch's performance as Kon even
though I had heard like the Khan jokes
and knowing that Khan was the ultimate
villain in the Star Trek movie franchise
I didn't have any of that built into me
of Ricardo Montalban when I watched this
film so I like Benedict Cumberbatch's
performance a lot ever since I've seen
Star Trek 2 ratha thought I had
revisited this movie but I feel like
you've been at it come retch it's a lot
of crap for this film I'm like why I
really think in this portrayal in this
movie I thought he does a great job yeah
well and I think - maybe there's some
backlash against the fact that they
blatantly lied about who he's playing
they're like that's really definitely
not Kron oh he is and it's not at all in
tune with you know you watch Wrath of
Khan that Conda Haig is so different
yeah you didn't have to call him Kannan
into darkness that was the thing mm-hmm
a lot of eight kong-kong there's no need
to call him Khan in the movie yeah it's
just to get those butts in the seats cuz
people know the significance man yeah
but under a different name you'd see
that oh this is a 100% different
character so it's kind of I don't know
if it's the right word is insulting but
it's nowhere near honoring the original
Khan yeah and on top of that the lie
that you're talking about it's true I
love the Austin Powers a mini-me team-up
in Goldmember in fact I wouldn't have
made it an honorable mention I would put
it yeah Jota is not one of the other
ones off for that I had taken Conn and
Kirk off personally yeah because I'm
befuddled did that made it to the second
spot on this but Clarice Starling dr.
Hannibal Lecter is a good call yeah yeah
you know my Jodie Foster didn't return
for Hannibal because she was traumatized
by the experience of making this first
movie mm-hmm because when Anthony
Hopkins became good friends and she was
like no I just can't
it was because in the Hannibal movie
have you seen it I've seen the scene
where people are eating ray Liotta's
brain you see in that scene in the book
Clarice starts to eat decides to partake
and they kind of end on a good like I
don't know if there were lovers in the
book or something but there's not a note
word that bonded yeah that's how was in
the original script and she didn't want
to go down and now she wasn't down for
some reason when they cast Julianne
Moore they rewrote it anyway there's an
alternate timeline where Jodie Foster
did do that it's a great choice for
number one though especially because
like this is a very broad list in terms
of like the kinds of films - yeah
good the bad the ugly I thought was a
real nice choice also on the more
morally ambiguous side of the spectrum
but that is a pretty classic two sides
of the fence sure that's true Captain
Barbossa and and she's very good sparrow
Barbosa and Jack Sparrow is kind of a
defining team-up to me because they're
totally protagonist antagonist in the
first Pirates of the movie and then by
the time you get to Pirates three
they're working together and then then
four they're still working together they
butt heads and stuff and they kind of
dick each other over they're just like
buddy cops now par five you care a lot
about Barbosa and he even has a
wonderful if you haven't seen it has a
wonderful final moment in that movie
where you really care about him so I
would totally say Barbosa Jack Sparrow
on the list with Gollum and Frodo count
because he wasn't really pitched as a
it's like you didn't know if you should
trust Gollum or not and I'm Return of
the King you see what happened but it
seemed like the whole path of Gollum
initially was a path of redemption but
then ultimately he he doesn't be
redeemed but that you do see moments
were like is he trying to betray them
around you know what I mean yeah I feel
like you learn early on that he's not
someone you should trust so it's not
really a team-up it's more of a
manipulation team-up instead of yeah
they're really working together and they
like each other not use each other but
by this lists rules you know like come
on and curtain we're just using yeah
exactly exactly yeah and I mean Gollum
is certainly at least a type of
antagonist even if he's not the villain
so to speak you know what about [ __ ]
Darth Vader and Luke Skywalker
oh hey Return of the Jedi it's an iconic
scene right I feel the conflict within
you let go of your hate if they're gonna
include like frickin five minutes of
movies here is the team-up why don't you
go over Vader and Luke Skywalker very
surprised because just like you know
Star Wars is Star Wars yeah there's also
uh you know Ocean's thirteen oh yeah
yeah they bring in Terry Benedict right
yeah and they even bring in
no and I got the facts wrong am i yeah
you could be ready I was born ready
what about Wonder Woman in BVS feminism
is wrong but then they work together
totally totally I mean women have no
place being in a superhero movie let
alone in a superhero fight but hey they
let her be there and they got the fight
done so technically that counts
exactly well you know Bill Gates and
Steve Jobs oh yeah these guys hate it
what about Captain America what I'm
sorry oh yeah most definitely I mean
they're not villain and hero to each
other but you know Bucky's villain to a
lot of other mean if they put down comic
book movies fandom related material be
like oh just trying to pander them you
don't do that Oh where's it where's the
fandom that's what obtained the horny
teenagers and Jason Voorhees in Freddy
vs. Jason because that movie makes a
choice as to who is the lesser of two
evils see where my horror ass besides
silence in last anyway I think we came
up with some good additions here yeah
thanks guys for participate in this
video and Mikael thanks for requesting
this buddy I want to take this
opportunity to share with audiences
something I didn't know that you
educated me on so I feel it's important
everyone else knows about it too he
taught me this
okay the Bourne Identity would Matt
Damon was not the first Bourne Identity
adaptation did you know that oh did they
make it for TV they did I feel like I
heard this reason they made it for TV I
saw the trailer star Richard Chamberlain
as Jason Bourne and it looked terrible
what kind of terrible we talkin it
looked like I kind of want to watch this
because it looks so bad it must be
entertaining and I would love to see how
different it is from the Matt Damon
interpretation directed by Doug Liman
weirdly so much more shaky-cam
yeah shaky cam The Bourne Identity I
know so much more Shh
guys he's a huge spy fanatic my friend
McHale and now you guys know that Matt
Damon was not the first one to do the
Bourne Identity and more people need to
acknowledge the work of Richard
Chamberlain in this terrible look in
1988 hey by the way but I can't judge
can't judge it just off the trailer
don't judge a book by it's cover you
know plenty of people on the internet do
that guys you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell any good guy bad guy team ups that
we did not think of that should have
been on this list comment below
take care